student nonviolent coordinating
committee in mississippi
and from 1969 to 1976 he taught
mathematics at a secondary school in
tanzania
currently he's pursuing a phd in
philosophy at harvard university
while serving as a volunteer teacher in
an experimental math program at the
martin luther king jr school in
cambridge massachusetts
in 1982 robert moses received a
macarthur foundation fellowship which
continues until 1987. i'm happy to
introduce you to robert paris moses
um
to the
people
all the people
and the people who are sitting at the
symposium
and people who are in the audience
i'm not a scholar
and i don't have a paper
and
our job was to
comment
on the papers that were
presented and
that's what i'm going to try to
confine myself
to doing
one thing that
strikes me
as
i'm listening and reading the papers
is that
we're in the
very initial stages
of trying to
figure out
and write about
the movement
alden morris didn't have a chance to
finish his paper and i'm sorry about
that i wish that he had
there is a part in his paper that i was
going to start off with
and he didn't get to read it
so i want to to read it to you
he talked about this first paragraph he
said that
he was talking about king and the black
protest tradition
and he said that the most outstanding
feature of king was his absolute
identification with the poor
oppressed black masses
and he talked about his personalism
that the clue to the meaning of ultimate
reality is found in personality
that is in metaphysical and
philosophical grounding
for the idea of a personal god
a metaphysical basis for the dignity and
worth
of all human personality
and then this paragraph he didn't get to
read
every human being
has etched in his personality and these
are king's words
the indelible stamp of the creator
the worth of an individual does not lie
in the measure of his intellect
his racial origin
or his social position
human worth
lies in relatedness to god
and i wanted to pick up from that last
sentence
that human worth
lies in relatedness to god
and ask a question of us how
are we to
understand our relatedness to god
and
one way in which we understand that is
through a metaphor
that is there is a long-standing
metaphor
about our relatedness to god
namely that god is
an ocean of consciousness
and we are individual waves
in that ocean of
consciousness and we are to think of
ourselves
as
related to god
as the wave
is related to the ocean
and you think about that it's trying to
give you a picture
right because we know the ocean
and we see the waves and they rise and
fall
on the bosom of the ocean
and
so we
in that metaphor
rise and fall in the bosom of god
now
metaphors
are what we use to help us understand
reality
and the historians use them
and the scientists use them
i remember
a very important metaphor
in my study of philosophy of science was
the neurath metaphor
now otto noirath
was a
scientist he lived in vienna social
scientist
and he had a metaphor about
the ship of science
on the ocean
of knowledge
and he said that the ship of science is
a ship which
is floating on the ocean of knowledge
and the scientist is a little man in
that ship who is trying to rebuild it
all the time
but he can never come to dark can't ever
land in any port
and he has to learn how to keep the ship
afloat
while he's rebuilding it
and he has to do it on this ocean
and what he was getting at in that
metaphor was that
the effort of the scientists to create
a precise language of science
is forever bounded
by the ocean of just ordinary language
out of which that precise language
has to evolve
and the scientist is apt to forget that
and as i have to get carried away with
his precise language
now i mentioned that metaphor because
in mississippi in 1966
when we were having our conferences at
waveland
that metaphor stuck in my mind i have
forgotten what it meant
but
the metaphor of the boat and the ocean
and rebuilding it stuck in my mind
and we were having a conference in
wavelength in which
none of us were allowed to sign our
names to any papers
because nick was
fearful of
the influence of
people who
might have more influence than other
people
and was
trying an experiment in democracy and so
everyone was asked to write position
papers without signing their name to it
and so in one of my
papers that i wrote i mentioned the
metaphor
that
snake
is a boat
in the middle of an ocean
and we're inside that boat
and we're trying to rebuild it
we have nowhere to dock
and our problem is how can we stay
afloat
while we're rebuilding it
and not sink
well somebody asked jim what is that
one of the field sectors what is this
business about a boat
and jim got up in the meeting he said
well somebody asked me about
the boat and the ocean
and he said that's a metaphor
and he went on to explain what a
metaphor was
and then said but i don't like the
metaphor i don't like all about it i
think we don't
want to say that it's an ocean we need
to get some direction in it
and say that our boat is on a river
that is moving someplace
well
cleveland celeste
took up on that metaphor and
then came out with a book which he
called the river of no return
and as you know some historians have
also taken up the metaphor of a river
vincent harding in trying to explain
the whole tradition of black protest
well
alden mars presented us with a metaphor
this morning
and i want to get back to his metaphor
what he said was that
the thesis of this essay is that the
quality and success of king's leadership
stemmed from the outgrowth of large
social and historical factors
which converged with the unique
combinations of qualities
rooted in king's personality
so here we have the metaphor of
convergence
and it's a metaphor
right it's a picture
he's groping for something to try to
give us some sense of what was happening
and it's the convergence of these large
social
factors which he listed
and
personal factors in king's life
which he also listed
and my question is how
to him and to us
how are we to understand this metaphor
how are we to make sense of it
well
one way
of understanding it is to
look back
at the question
which this metaphor is the answer to or
leads us
into
the answer to
and that question is in the preceding
paragraph of his paper
how is the emergence and success of such
a leader
to be explained
now i want you to consider the metaphor
again about god
that god is an ocean of consciousness
and we are the
waves
on that ocean
and think of that metaphor as a metaphor
about the movement
that the movement is
an ocean of
consciousness protest rebellion
organizing
and fill in other things that the
movement is an ocean of
and that the people in the movement
were the waves
on that ocean
that's how i always thought about the
movement
and about
my relationship to it and
snake and other people's relationship to
it
was the movement which was this ocean
and we were out there we were the waves
on the ocean
now when you think about the movement in
that way you can ask a question
different from the one that alden asked
alden's question is how is the emergence
and success of such a leader
to be explained
and we can ask
rather the question
how is the emergence
and the repression
the success
and the failure
of such a movement
to be explained
as we want to shift
our attention
right from the wave
to the ocean
because
the wave is not the ocean
no matter even if it's a tidal wave
it has no meaning
apart from that ocean
the idea is that
the history any history of the movement
when we talk about it
have to talk also about its failures
its false starts
as well as its successes
we have to offer to our young people
an understanding of why king was
assassinated
as well as why he became noble peace
prize winner
but not only king
right we have to
offer to them an understanding of why
mega evers
herbert lee lewis allen
goodman cheney schweiner
malcolm x
those two kennedy brothers
why all those people were assassinated
from 1961 to 1971
and the point is that king's
assassination has no meaning
apart from the assassination of all
those people you cannot
understand it
as an isolated event
and they belong
to the ocean that was the movement
right
that's what has to be studied
to get a deeper understanding
about who and what
dr king was
well that really is my major point
that
we can ask and should ask
of the historians
that they offer us
a history of the movement
and
that
through that history of the movement
then we can understand
the relationship of
dr king to the movement
but without that history of the movement
it's as meaningless as trying to
understand the wave without the concept
of the ocean
there just is no understanding to be had
and what we're left with is
frustration
it's a frustration that
dr king's sister expressed in the press
room
in connection with young people who
don't know how to relate to dr king
because they see him as a god
so they have no concept that they too
can be like him
and that's what happens when
the focus is is wrong it's misplaced
[Music]
now
i wanted to
take
into consideration what
some of the conceptual signposts
of the movement
are
that is what i've
thought about
over the years
what were important things in the
movement
and just put them out there for the
historians to
think
about
and
they may come up later in some of the
other papers so i'm not saying that they
haven't already thought about them
there was always within the movement a
tension between organizing and leading
or organizing and mobilizing
and you can trace the history of the
movement in terms of certain great
mobilizations yes
it was albany georgia there was
birmingham there was selma alabama
but you can also trace the history of
the movement in terms of certain
real organizing efforts
there was the organization of
sclc
there was the organization of snick
there was the organization of the
nashville
city movement
there was the organization of the march
on washington
and you can trace in the movement
the tension between
people
in their roles as organizers and as
leaders
and try to
get some sense of
what that meant
um
i think of ella baker
she was a great organizer and she was a
leader too
but one of the characteristics of the
organizer is that
their work emerges and they subside i
mean if you think of the wave in the
ocean
at a certain point they subside back
into the ocean and what you see is what
they organized or what their their work
snick is a work of alabaca
but it was snake that emerged not a
hella
the march on washington was a worker by
ruston
but it was martin with the king
who emerged not fired
and the point is that bayern never
organized that march so that he should
himself personally merge
it was organized and a setting in which
someone like king could emerge
and buyers know that
and he set out to do just that
and that's the mark of the organizer
ella didn't set up snick
in such a way that she could possibly
emerge as the leader of it
quite the
contrary ella organized
helped organize nick in such a way that
she could never possibly be
[Music]
the leader of it
[Music]
and in doing that she taught us about
organizing
jim lawson in nashville
organized the nashville city movement
and it was that movement that rescued
the freedom rights
and penetrated into mississippi
it was that movement and it was the only
movement in the whole country at that
time
that was prepared and absolutely
determined to get back on that burning
bus
nobody else
nobody else
not anybody
else in the whole country
was prepared to get back on that bus
and jim lawson
taught and organized those students
but he didn't emerge as their leader
their leaders went on to become leaders
of snake
john lewis and dying nash
so there is in the movement these great
examples of organizers
and their organizing efforts
and
i miss that and this
it seems like the
it doesn't make good copy right
but
it really helped
it made the movement
i mean it was the tissues and the bone
and the inner structure of the movement
um there is a question of nationalism
and i don't have much to say about that
but
what i'm missing is the understanding
of
the rise of nationalism worldwide
in
the period following world war ii
and how it manifested itself in this
country
in malcolm in robert williams
and then in
black power movement
again with
this feeling of this real an ocean
of
something
whatever it is that's nationalism
and its manifestation
within this country
at a time when it
didn't expect it to be manifested
there's something else i wanted to say
about nationalism but i've forgotten
the other
concept is
non-violence
and mrs king mentioned it in the
conference room where we had the press
room
and i'm sure that that's going to be
taken up
in other
papers
but
i was
watching and aware of
non-violence and how it was being played
out within the movement
and i've always
felt that somehow
the non-violence that was committed to
non-violence as a way of life
and not just as a tactic
to be used in
mobilizations
but
a real
organizing tool whereby a person tried
to organize his own life
that that
somehow
never caught hold within the movement
and
i just would like i think that that's
something that needs needs real
investigation
the person who comes to mind again is
jim lawson
because jim is the only person i know in
the movement that actually trained
people
who then went out and tried to practice
that non-violence as a way of life i'm
thinking of
the nashville
people a segment of those nashville
people
who became so prominent and snick
and
we all agreed on non-violence as a
tactic yes
in certain demonstrations
up at a certain point within the history
but
non-violence as a way of life
escaped us at that point
it certainly escaped me
um
i could never talk about it to
the people we were working with they
carry guns the farm is in mississippi i
mean
carrying a gun protecting your home that
was a way of life
um it we need a real understanding of
where nonviolence
really fit in and
with whom
how
i say that because
there was
within this country
during the time of the movement
and approach to god
and to non-violence which we were
ignorant of
and that was the approach through yoga
which was being introduced in this
country
before and during and after the movement
but
we never connected with it
and
that approach to non-violence emphasize
certain spiritual
practices
certain spiritual disciplines
it's an approach which i have tried now
to study
for these past
years
and in trying to study it i understand
what we did not have
when we were in the movement in the 60s
we didn't have
access
to that kind of knowledge about
how it is
you actually work with yourself
with very simple exercises
with very simple practices to transform
yourself
um to make
more manifest
that god
which we are
a wave of consciousness of
so
i say that because i think that
in the movement which is coming
or the
evolving again
that if there is going to be
non-violence involved in it then
we have to prepare ourselves for
that kind of
effort
and mrs king mentioned
dr king's
spiritual discipline and
that's something that the historians
then need to
to tell us about also what
what was it and what did it consist
as well as looking into
what happened to non-violence
in the movement in its practices
and where did it play itself out
so
those ideas about organizing versus
leaders
and the complex role that people played
both as organizers and leaders you think
of a person that games him more
ramsey moore was a leader in cleveland
and would not be broached
he was the civil rights leader in
cleveland mississippi but he was an
organizer in mississippi
and never a leader
in the state as a whole
he moved like an organizer
never out front
working with people to help them set up
certain plans the voting plan for
example
but in his own town in his community
he was a leader now
civil rights workers got into trouble
when they didn't understand that
and tried to organize in amster's
territory
but all of these kinds of interplays
i think that we need
more of that
so
i guess what i'm
wanted to say in commenting on the
papers that
i don't i have a
question about alden's question
and i understand that
i'm not sure that he actually thinks of
the movement in that way maybe that was
just because of being presented
with
this conference because
they asked me
to write a paper about the conference
and i had two problems when i'm not a
scholar and i don't write papers
not
usually
and the other
i don't think about the movement in
terms of king
and
i was
understood that to write a paper this
was a conference about king
in the movement
and i have no qualms with that
but i never thought about the movement
in terms of king
i have always thought about them it
never occurred to me
to think about the movement in terms of
king i lived and breathed the movement
so i couldn't have written a paper
that focused on the movement in terms of
king
so it may be that
alden was limited in terms of the scope
of the conference
but it just wanted to point out that
that other question seems to me more
important
not the emergence and success of an
individual
but
first the emergence and the success
of
the failure and the repression of
the movement
and study at false thoughts as well as
its successes
its failures
as well as where it
won out
okay thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you bob
our second commentator is professor
howard zinn of boston university
professors zen scholarship is well known
within both history and political
science
he's written and edited 11 books
including laguardia in congress which
won the american historical
association's beverage prize
snick the new abolitionist post-war
america 1945 1971
a people's history of the united states
and others
his published articles and essays are
legion and his writings have been
translated into japanese italian
norwegian french and serbo croatian
not many scholars can boast of that
it thus gives me a great pleasure to
introduce professor howard zinn
[Applause]
i'm going to deliver this in serbo
creation
oh this has been a remarkable day
and
i suppose because at first i
i started off wondering
what was going to happen
[Music]
what direction is this going to go in
worrying about it
as i always worry when people do history
because you know what happens when
people do history very often
they do history
and it's done and there's nothing left
to say and nowhere else to go
and it goes into the library
and then people
ignore it
maybe maybe rightfully
[Music]
but what we've had here is an
interesting
development i think
and that is
starting from clay carson's
exhortation to us and to himself
not to make this an empty exercise in
nostalgia
but to
make it meaningful for the future to
have it carry on
and this is the way i always thought of
history and this is the way i've tried
to write and do history
in a way that
is aimed at the present and the future
and what are we going to do now
and so i appreciated what clay carson
had to say i appreciate that thrust of
his of his argument
and
um
he's taking the the edge off the
the
notion of charisma
and trying to get us to look more
realistically at the person
beneath that charisma
and in alden morris
in his very careful analysis of the
movement and the interrelationship
between a king
and the movement it seems to me
trying to
tell us
how
we might think of movements and
individuals in the future and then
bob made that both
explicit
and poetic
as he usually does
by the way when
when i heard him say how in wavelength i
remember waveland and i remember how the
people and snake
wrote these papers anonymously and no
one can tell me that when jim foreman
came across that metaphor he didn't know
who wrote that metaphor
uh
um
we all deal with metaphors but some deal
with them more than others
so
i'd like to
try to continue
in
that vein
that is trying to
extract from
the history of that time from the
movement and king
some
things for us to think about
uh
and
bob's point
uh about the
relationship
between king and the movement his
emphasis on the ocean his emphasis on
the movement has talked about king as a
wave and ella baker as a wave and amzie
moore as a wave
uh you know we could add bob moses as a
wave
uh and so and many other waves
uh
and uh
very important for us today that is why
we looking at this why are we studying
this if it's not for the fact that today
we face problems as serious
or more serious than the ones we faced
in the 1960s
and without a present going exciting
rousing movement which we can all
join that is a situation which we know
demands enormous effort and we were
wondering where that effort is coming
from and therefore we need all the
guidance we can get
and that that bit of guidance that we
just heard is very important that we
cannot wait for charismatic leaders we
cannot look for charismatic leaders
cannot
and this goes directly against you know
modern culture and it goes directly
against american culture and all this
emphasis on stars
people magazine
and celebrities and
who is going to be elected president as
if that is the most important thing
you see who is
i know i'm offending some people by
saying that as they think of who is
sitting in the white house but
there but really the the the american
culture
which has become
uh
too much of a worldwide culture in its
emphasis on who will save us
in my work in american history i've been
only too aware of how
kids in school are
taught
as i was taught when i went to school
taught american history as a succession
of saviors
the founding fathers saved us
from england
and then lincoln freed the slaves
and roosevelt ended the depression
and well after that it got vague
but it was only after i got through my
formal training in history and i began
to read for myself that i realized there
was a lot going on in this country long
before those founding fathers got
together in philadelphia in fact the
things that these ordinary people did
like
rebel from time to time caused these
founding fathers to get together and
wonder how can we contain such
rebellions
and lincoln did not free the slaves but
it was this enormous movement
uh that went on in the 30 years before
the civil war which rose to a crescendo
with black abolitionists and white
abolitionists and
yes a movement of people which went
beyond those waves of lincoln and
garrison and phillips and even frederick
douglass who was a great wave but the
enormous numbers of people involved in
that movement which
led to
sort of the end of slavery
but
sort out
and and this has been the history
of
of this country as not told in the
history books the story of movements
which made whatever bits of progress we
have made in this country and on top of
which movements leaders rose
and and were visible
the leaders
the waves
we most cherish
are those
who knew what they were
who knew that they were waves on the
ocean
who who understood that
they were there because of the movement
and
they could help it along but after they
would be gone the movement must continue
and
one of the
i thought remarkable things
about
dr king
was that
exalted as he was in the press and made
much of and winner of the nobel prize
and and we know all those things
uh
and
and he was
tempted by this as everybody is in such
a situation such temptations are put
before people
uh who
become prominent and known you know
invitations to the white house in
caucuses in little meetings and
gatherings of the elite you see to
discuss strategy and and hardly anybody
is aversed
to and
can
resist that and and king
went in and out of that but at critical
moments
when decisions had to be made he very
often not always
because he wasn't perfect he knew that
he turned to
the the people who were in the movement
and and asked them what he should do
and i remember specifically and i just
heard this the other night because i was
in atlanta speaking to lonnie king who
was one of the leaders of the atlanta
student movement and he was telling me
how
at a certain point in the fall of 1960
during the boycott of rich's
department's store in atlanta uh lonnie
king and hershell sullivan the two
student leaders
her show was a student of mine at
spelman
and
i i always have to say who is my student
because that's how teachers exist
you see
and uh you know we would
just die if we couldn't say who our
students were
and they uh
uh hershell and and lonnie uh
decided we we have to have a critical
sit-in at rich's department store rich's
is the big domino which will topple all
the others and so they called
dr king and i said you've got because
they wanted media attention and king
would bring media you've got to come and
sit in with us on the bridge it riches
the bridges there's one of four eating
places that riches
and uh
and and king
uh hesitated
uh
he was
he was a human being
and he had his hesitations he didn't
rush into ever and and he said look i've
i've i'm on probation i've got four
months
facing me hard labor
sentenced in dekalb county which is even
worse than fulton county
and
and you know
and
and lonnie
said
but
you're a leader
and he
said where are we meeting on the bridge
and so he went and he was arrested and
sure enough he he went to jail and
there were moments like that the moment
in 1963 in
birmingham when king
drawn the thing about
i speak with such we all of us speak
with such arrogance
i i'm aware that of people you know who
are not here to defend themselves
against the things we say or to correct
what we know
or remember about them but
doctor dr king was
you know i think the kind of person who
when he met with the powers that be
even though he came out of the south and
the black stuff he
uh it was hard for him not to be nice to
them
and so
even though he sort of suspected maybe
they don't have our first interests at
heart you know uh kennedy and and john
doerr and burke marshall and that you
know
maybe they don't but he
he had to be nice to people that he was
meeting face to face
and uh and listen to them and so on so
he came to fred shuttlesworth in
birmingham and said they suggest that we
call the demonstrations in birmingham
off
for a while and chelsea said
no way
ah and king
they had already planned a press
conference and an agreement and so on
and and sheldon says no
and it was and now king could listen to
to marshall and dorr and kennedy or he
could
listen to a much
more
insignificant right in the lexicon of
the of the country man fred shuttleworth
but he knew that fred shuttlesworth was
one of those
people
uh one one of those other waves in the
movement
that when eisenhower was getting credit
for sending the troops to little rock in
1957 shuttlesworth and his wife had sent
their kids the first black kids into a
high school in birmingham they had
escorted their kids and fred
shuttlesworth was attacked by the clan
and beaten with chains and his wife was
stabbed
you see and all
and
federal agents were not around to help
them no troops were around to help them
nobody was around to help and and king
knew this and much more about
charlesworth and he went back and he
said no we're not going to i'm not going
to do that agreement like you say so i
think one of the
the
it is very important for people who have
been made big waves on the ocean
to understand who they are what they are
and where they come from and i think
that not always but often king
understood this and he respected the
kids in snake i was a little taken aback
clay where are you clay
when uh
when you talked about the snicks anger
or right or uh was the attacks
on king and it's true it's snick
resented very often you know all like
hoopla and publicity and the seizing
upon king and and and neglecting of
those people down there and the earth
who who were
the movement but i always i always found
in in my
time with snake and so that the snick
people as critical as they were king saw
him basically as one of their own
and knew that at certain times and again
not always
you know but at certain times he turned
to them and turned to the snake
people and listened to them paid
attention to them and i think that you
know that was very important
uh
and i i guess if there's anything
what i'm doing is i'm trying to think of
what what can we learn from that
experience both of the king's experience
and the movement both the ocean and the
waves what can we learn that is useful
for us today with the problems that we
face today and that that
that about us needing to create a
movement and not looking for leaders
knowing that if we if we
uh
that need is upon us and that that and
that job belongs to all of us and it
belongs to all of us
uh in in
because all of us are capable
not of heroic acts but of small acts and
movements come as a succession of small
acts this is one of the one of the great
things i have to say this i'm not saying
a lot about alden morris's paper but in
order to make up for what i'm not saying
about his paper i want to tell you that
you should read his book origins of the
civil rights movement which is i think
one of the most important books on the
civil rights movement that has come out
in this country and one of the things he
does in it is trace
the little things that happen that
people do that don't get into the
newspapers and don't get into the
history books but that add up to the the
links and connections and roots that
end up with
a movement yes and end up with then
leaders of the movement he'll become
famous but
what it suggests to us for the future is
that any one of us and all of us are
capable of becoming links small links uh
who
doing little things connecting with one
another and
organizing his links have to be
organized as bob said
uh
have
in that way the possibility of becoming
part of some great movement
now i i know you're all pressed for time
right and you would like me to finish in
two minutes right
however
i can't
you know
after all one of the things we learned
in that movement is civil disobedience
and uh
no i won't go on for too long but there
are just a few a few you know things i
want to say which i i think are
important even though the you know that
they're
specific and controversial and so on but
that's what we we need to do right we we
don't want placidity and kindness and
and sweetness and a lot you know and all
of that we we need we we need there are
things to do we have to remember certain
things from from that movement
and uh and and one of these things is
the skepticism of authority
and the the uh
just and this gets back to to the
skepticism that king very often showed
but not always but that all of us need
to show all the time that's skepticism
or authority another thing just sheer
honesty whatever whatever king's faults
worry and he certainly had them
as human beings do i felt there was one
saving
thing about him and that was his honesty
that he told the truth
and in this in this era of
why do i say this era of lies and
disinformation in every era when
governments lie and deceive us really
governments all over the world i mean
the first thing you know to know about
governments is the government's lie
you know and and deceive it's parts it's
not just something that happened
yesterday
and and to tell the truth to be honest
is absolutely essential ingredient of
people who work in every movement
because the truth is on the side
that is on our side
and lies are on their side and you know
what i mean by us and them
king it is very important to understand
king thought outside of the united
states and thought outside of of the
problems here and he thought about the
world he thought about south africa he
and when he spoke out on vietnam he
faced remember it took courage for king
to speak out on vietnam because he was
criticized by by some of the important
black leaders
uh there's one there's where he was at
one with snick and and with the ocean
and with the natural instincts of
of black people in the movement and a
lot of white people and knew that this
this was ugly and this was wrong and i i
don't doubt that king were alive today
protesting about what the united states
is doing in central america in nicaragua
and el salvador and the contras and all
that there's no doubt in my mind but
that he would he would be somewhere with
the people who are protesting that or
those veterans on the steps who are who
are
on a hunger strike to protest what the
united states is doing in central
america as what it did in vietnam
and uh
just a couple of more things
you see one is
that
uh and i'm thinking of david garrow in
his book on the fbi in king and i'm
thinking about the you know the fbi's
uh i almost said preoccupation but
that's a mild word uh
hysteria paranoia uh madness about
communism
you see which is a madness you know i
mean there's a reality of communism
there's the soviet union and
dictatorship and we
everybody knows that we don't have to be
told that
but there's a madness that is associated
with that word you know attached to
everything that anybody does which is an
attempt to make progress
and the idea is to use the word like a a
club
you see to beat people to the ground so
they won't speak anymore
you say
uh it's an intimidating thing you see
that i think of the democratic party not
taking the the equal time that was given
to them to respond to reagan after this
meeting right on at reykjavik the
democratic party said no we won't take
the time why because we we mustn't
criticize the president that will be
accused of being pro-communist
why that
that really got to me what timidity
timidity is not the word cowardice
you see
really
but king
you know when they said king this guy's
a communist and he's hanging around
the king didn't rush like some people do
get rid of this man
or when king they said don't go to
highlander folk school because
the fbi calls it a communist play you
know thereby calls the
ywca a communist place
you know
uh and king king went to highlander
anyway and king
you know
i think that that took some that's
important today because we know how that
word and how that hysteria is used to
absolutely paralyze people in deciding
what is right and wrong
two last things one on non-violence
the one on on violence which a lot of
people talked about more people talk
about is very often
and the
the establishment would like to us to
think of non-violence as just
non-violence
they would like to think of it as
passivity
uh
and it and and and dr king emphasized
non-violence is not passivity
because in fact the phrase that was used
and snick
made a point of this phrase nonviolent
direct action that was the phrase
yes
avoid violence but don't
be passive
being passive means don't just vote and
write to the your senator and so on get
out there
do things do what you have to do
liberties are not given they are taken
ah
and that that message of the movement
is a very powerful important message for
today in a time you know when we need to
take direct action to
do something about the the
distribution of wealth about the
economic system which which which dr
king to his credit became more and more
interested in more and more concerned
with
uh we need a movement around the issue
of the shameful waste of wealth in this
country 290 billion dollars for stupid
things
and when people are in need all over
this country
final just final thing
uh
uh
and i am
concentrating on dr king
keeping in mind what bob said about king
being a wave on the ocean about the
movement being thing because i think all
right it's
yes we can learn from every wave so long
as we know what it is who it is what its
limitations are
and
the there was something
in dr king which is tremendously
important and which is necessary in
every movement in which bob also
uh represented in his own way and that
is the spiritual quality of a movement
whether it's religion whether it's yoga
whether it is emotionalism whether
it is music or art or whatever it is a
movement needs that spiritual quality
because they have
you know who i mean by today they have
the the money and the guns and so on and
therefore we need everything we can do
to strengthen ourselves and that
spirituality
and and dr king
expressed that and he gave us hope and
faith and we need a lot of that for the
future thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you howard
our first speaker of the afternoon is
the distinguished historian professor
louis r harland of the university of
maryland
professor harlan's pulitzer
prize-winning biography of booker t
washington together with the 13 volume
edition of the booker t washington
papers which he edited with raymond w
smock have set a lofty standard in
historical writing and editing
among his other works is a book entitled
separate and unequal public school
campaigns and racism in the southern
seaboard states 19